[Music]
serendipity has been around for 62 years
and it's a fun place in the city where
you can come relax and really indulge
the golden opulence sundae was created
for serendipities 50th golden
anniversary and we partnered with
Guinness World Records and getting the
most expensive sundae in the world to
order the golden opulence sundae it
takes 48 hours advance notice because
all the ingredients for the sundae are
flown in the sundae is housed in a
Baccarat crystal goblet and that is the
same goblet that is used in the Vatican
we have three scoops of Tahitian vanilla
ice cream that are infused with
Madagascar vanilla and that is air
freighted over rolled in 23 carat edible
gold we used the world's most expensive
chocolate which is Amadei porcelana
and the world's rarest chocolate which
is Amadei Cho the cocoa beans are grown
in an island off of the coast of
Venezuela they're a certain amount
harvested per year making them very rare
we have Rajas which are almonds covered
in gold the sugar candies from Paris
take about a month to make we have sugar
flour that takes about eight hours to
make it's totally edible then we have
caviar that's infused with passion fruit
and our MEAC we probably sell one or two
Sundays per month we've had a Saudi
prince come and buy them for his whole
table and pay in cash people come from
around the world to indulge in this
edible work of art
you
you